ab nächstem jahr soll es möglich sein
pauschalurlaub auf der internationalen
raumstation iss
die us-raumfahrtbehörde nasa bietet dann
30 tägige mission für privatastronautin
astronauten an um ihr eigenes
mondprogramm mit dem eingenommenen geld
auf den weg zu bringen preis wird wird
das ganze für die urlauber aber nicht
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich faszinierendes seines videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
hier nicht herzlich willkommen und danke
für euren themenvorschlag in der telli
am community klicks wollte beim
evangelischen kirchentag in dortmund wo
ich das erste social media team mit
menschen mit behinderung mit der
stiftung es vater mitbegründet die nasa
plant genau zwei kurze missionen pro
jahr für privat astronauten insgesamt
zwölf weltraum touristen und
touristinnen steht dann also der urlaub
an bord der internationalen raumstation
iss offen hin und rückflug sollen mit
zwei verschiedenen anbietern
durchgeführt werden zum einen mit ihnen
mast us raumfahrtunternehmen spacex und
zum anderen mit dem us-flugzeugbauer
boeing beide unternehmen entwickeln
derzeit raumkapseln für die nasa bis
heute hatten die raumfahrzeuge von
spacex von boeing allerdings noch keine
menschen mit an bord und gerade ist ja
eine space extraction kapsel beim test
in flammen aufgegangen bis zu 30 tage
lang können die missionen für die privat
astronautinnen und astronauten dauern
doch das ist wohl nur für die ganz
reichen unter uns wirklich denn billig
urlaub sieht anders aus
rund 58 millionen dollar also
umgerechnet knapp 52 millionen euro
sollen allein der hin- und rückflug
kosten sprich die nasa astronauten und
astronautinnen fliegen kostenlos mit
werden an falcons start kostet ungefähr
diese summe dazu kommen dann noch die
kosten für das leben an bord der
raumstation
das ist für einen monat rund eine
million denn umgerechnet kostet eine
nacht 31.000 euro aber dafür gibt es
dann auch vollpension nachzulesen ist
das alles in einer sehr detaillierten
preisliste die nasa veröffentlicht hat
in der vollpension enthalten sind
beispielsweise die versorgung mit luft
nahrung trainingsgeräten und
medizinische ausrüstung strom wird mit
umgerechnet
35 euro pro kilowatt stunde abgerechnet
kost bei uns so knapp 30 cent pro
gigabyte datenübertragung sind rund 44
euro zu zahlen und der toilettengang und
die regenerative lebenshaltung sind
schon im preis von eben 31.000 euro pro
nacht enthalten den ganzen plan verfolgt
die nasa wohl um irgendwie das geld für
die ziemlich utopische mond-mission 2024
zusammenzubekommen
laut nasa webseite ermöglicht dieses
projekt zitat die nutzung staatlicher
ressourcen für kommerzielle aktivitäten
und schafft die möglichkeit für private
astronauten missionen im erdnahen orbit
und zur raumstation
die weltraumbehörde wird die einnahmen
in ihrem ihr mondprogramm fließen lassen
und so eine solide raumfahrt wirtschaft
aufbauen sprich auch der nasa ist
inzwischen aufgefallen dass das geld für
eine mond-mission hinten und vorne nicht
reichen
nasa sprecher william gerstenmaier fast
das folgendermaßen zusammen die
kommerzialisierung der entleeren
umlaufbahn wird es uns ermöglichen
ressourcen zu bündeln damit wir bis zum
jahr 2024 dsv und den nächsten mann auf
den mond bringen können es ist ein
erster schritt eine nachhaltige mond
präsenz zu schaffen und außerdem
vorbereitungen für zukünftige maße uns
bestätigen
wir bringen menschen in das sonnensystem
etwas mehr als eine halbe milliarde euro
dürfte so zusammenkommen was aber immer
noch viel zu wenig ist um eine
mond-mission realität werden zu lassen
so ermöglicht die nasa also die
kommerzielle nutzung der internationalen
raumstation und der besuch von weltraum
touristen ist diesbezüglich nur ein
aspekt den laut dem plan ist es
demnächst auch unternehmen erlaubt auf
der iss produzieren oder auch marketing
aktivitäten nachzugehen allerdings nur
unter der voraussetzung dass diese
projekte einen bezug zur nase haben
dafür dürfen die firmen dann die
ressourcen der nasa nutzen 5 prozent pro
jahr sind für solch eine kommerzielle
nutzung vorgesehen interessierte
unternehmen können auswählen ob sie
eigene astronautinnen und astronauten
zur iss schicken oder aber auf die
arbeitskraft und erfahrungen der nasa
astronauten und astronauten
zurückgreifen wollen die möglichkeit
urlaub auf der iss zu machen ist
übrigens nicht wirklich neu denn schon
hatte der erste von mehreren
weltraumtouristen urlaub auf der iss
gemacht dennis tito ein amerikanischer
multimillionär die nasa war von seinem
besuch damals allerdings alles andere
als begeistert sie sahen den amerikaner
als sicherheitsrisiko für ihre forschung
an bord von so you see 32 grad tito die
reise zur iss an und erreichte sie
zusammen mit zwei kosmonauten für ihn
hat es sich gelohnt tito punkte nach
hause
das hier oben übertrifft meine schönsten
träume da hat die nasa will ihre
ansichten über weltraumtouristen
inzwischen geändert und es zeigt sich
einst die forschung auf der iss ist wohl
nicht mehr so nötig oder anders sie
findet nur staatlich stadt unternehmen
ist sie meist zu teuer und die wartezeit
zu lange und obwohl es lange wartelisten
für forschungsprojekte auf der
internationalen raumstation gibt scheint
die nasa hier die prioritäten verändert
zu haben es ist schon ein bisschen
traurig dass es jetzt zu einem
disneyland im weltraum verkommen zu
lassen und marketingaktivitäten im
weltraum das hört sich schon ziemlich
schräg an ich fürchte mit dieser aktion
ist niemandem geholfen das geld für die
mond-mission 2024 kommt nicht zusammen
und die forschung auf der iss wird in
mitleidenschaft gezogen schade aber
vielleicht laufen ja privatunternehmen
der nasa demnächst den rang ab amazon
plant riesige weltraum kolonie feld
gravitation durch rotation anklicken
anschauen und breaking lab abonnieren
hammer kanal bis dann bleibt dran